the jurogan experience hey uh did you
watch the canelo fight this weekend
i was working i didn't see it at all i
saw the highlights
jesus broke his face bro he hit so hard
broke that orbital bone he's one of
those guys that like you know some guys
just have power
right but he works on it all the time
that's what i say he's the most
in every fight he's the most improved
fighter he always goes back
and fixes anything he saw wrong yep well
the danny jacobs fight remember this
head movement
yep it's i mean it gave danny problems
it would give anybody
problems but it was also like he was
showing his head movement in that fight
yeah because they used to say he just
walked right in and then he fixed it
there was a video of it there's a video
of deontay wilder uh yesterday i saw it
and he's looking really good malik scott
king is training him now
what is he doing with him oh he looks
like a completely different fighter i
think if you could find that
oh is he like using a lot of jabs and
planting his feet and he looks like a
boxer now he doesn't look like a wild
man just
leaping off his feet and throwing these
wild punches he looks and i'm excited to
see
him fight now because he looked really
sharp look like a real boxer now
don't you think he needs a few fights
like that
with lower lower tier competition look
at that yeah
look at that it's sitting on him bam the
jab is very important
but he's gonna need some you know some
tune-up fights don't you think
he should definitely have a just to see
how that style works in the ring
but he's moving you see the way he's
moving but again he's
a guy that has [ __ ] preposterous
power
yeah isn't it power's so weird you know
it is because he's so thin you're like
where's it coming from well tommy hearns
yeah well tommy yeah tommy hearns had he
knocked roberto duran out cold the only
guy ever
second round there's just guys that just
have preposterous power and canelo
is a guy that has power but is
constantly working on there's a
great clip of him working with uh andy
ruiz
and they're uh you know that that shield
that weird hand shield
yeah that they hold up when you hold it
for hooks and he's like this is not for
speed this is just power just power
he's like don't don't try to be fast
with this just power and you see him
just
boom everything is and so in that fight
with billy joe
and billy joe kept doing that that same
lean over and over
like after he would punch he would lean
out of the way and he just timed it
perfectly with that uppercut yep
and threw everything in it that's the
thing he he
really watches you in a fight he's not
like some
some knucklehead who knows how to he
really pays it he's very aware
and to me i was never a canelo guy
before but after the past
five fights i was like you know what uh
if i'm not a canelo fan now i'm a
[ __ ] hater
but i am a fan now because i really
appreciate his work ethic you know the
way he [ __ ]
look at it yeah this see it's it's about
power
yeah see this is this is the thing
they're working on
and he'll do that over and over and over
again so he's a guy who already had big
power
but he's constantly working and
developing that power
so like in a fight like the saunders
fight there was massive consequences to
anything that saunders did
canelo is in this weird place where he's
kind of cleaned out the division right
he's got caleb plant
right and not just that division he's
kind of cleaned out a lot of divisions
triple g is still in the in the [ __ ]
running
which is interesting because he hasn't
fought in two years no he fought
recently
triple g [ __ ] last year yeah it's been a
year though definitely since he fought
last
um i don't think it's quite a year
because i i was in texas
i watched it in texas live or yeah yeah
um see find out when he when he fought
but he looked [ __ ] good dude he not
only looked good he looked ripped
so i was like hmm piss test please
because he's like 38 and now he's got
he thinks he's bordering 40 real quick
looked as good as he's ever looked he
looked phenomenal
december oh december there you go okay
so it's not been that long then
yeah so uh yeah so so is he fighting
when the [ __ ] is he fighting again then
well they're talking about him possibly
fighting canelo he's i don't think
that's a good fight for him anymore
for him maybe not but maybe the last
chance at romance
right how much more of an option does he
have where's he gonna go
where what else does he have but the
first fight i thought he won definitely
i was at that one yeah i thought he won
the first fight i was ringside there the
second fight was very close
very close and teddy atlas was saying
they should have given it to triple g
a lot of other people favored canelo but
a much better performance for canelo
but i think canelo as like we said these
these guys
like camaro usman like canelo alvarez
like these guys who are just
consummate champions you're just going
to get a better version of them
every single time they step into the
ring catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience